our job number one
you know is to split the russian chinese
alliance that's our best hope for
prevailing in the new cold war that is
our highest priority to split that
alliance
and uh uh
and i i think it's possible to do it uh
you know because i think putin uh and
russia has been discontented with that
alliance i think they understand russia
is smart enough to see that china in the
long run
after they defeat us okay there's going
to be a world war iv between the
totalitarian powers and i think
russia realizes because of the
they've built up china to be such a
strong power
uh and they have a billion people uh
that china in the long run is a bigger
threat to russia than the west is uh and
the uh the uh uh i also think russia is
kind of disappointed in its relationship
with china china is obviously on their
side now and they're getting benefits
from china now but the relative benefits
that have come from this relationship
have much more favored china than russia
in terms of economic benefits in terms
of technology transfer in terms of
geostrategic influence i think
putin was waiting
for
trump to hit the reset button and it was
general flynn's plan his national
security advisor he even wrote a book
about it to say you know what we've got
to do is hit the reset button with
russia to split the russian chinese
alliance and putin was just waiting for
that to happen but the democrat party
made it impossible to happen because of
these false charges that
trump was putin's puppet and so he never
got a chance to hit hit the reset button
and the democrat party has gone on with
this mantra about russia russia russia
being the uh you know being evil and uh
and and
and now over the ukraine war uh you know
uh how uh he's a war criminal so how
could we make common cause with them and
all
all of that and the focus is on
on defeating russia and the ukraine war
and uh
uh
we're not gonna be able to defeat russia
in the ukraine war i mean there's just
so much to talk about here because if
russia has to they will resort to
nuclear weapons chemical and biological
weapons they've cheated on the chemical
and biological weapons treaties they
have very sophisticated offensive
chemical and biological weapons they've
cheated on all the arms control treaties
and yes i'm starry state department i
think they've cheated on the new start
treaty too it's the last treaty that
they're supposed to be obeying okay
which is it controls the strategic
warheads that can reach us you know i
think they probably have cheated on new
start as well and they have a huge
advantage there we and that we know
they've got a ten to one advantage at
least in tactical nuclear weapons they
probably have a two to one advantage in
strategic nuclear weapons and they have
the world's most advanced
passive and active
strategic defenses you know there are
thousands of shelters and bunkers
hundreds of deep underground facilities
for the russian political military
leadership they can they can protect the
top three hundred thousand political
military leaders in russia in deep
underground facilities that are under
hundreds of meters of granite that are
impervious to nuclear attack that's
where putin was uh i think it was on
february 27th when he put his forces on
nuclear alert so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]